ciao ragazzi bentornati una puntata di
cucina buttata non so se vedete ma oggi
sono particolarmente rilassato e felice
perché oltre a stare cremoso ancora una
volta collaboro con i nostri amici di
philadelphia lina scorsa collaborazione
che abbiamo fatto con loro abbiamo
preparato una cheesecake a castello che
potete vedere cliccando da qualche parte
qua sopra qualora vogliate fare un
qualcosa di dolce oggi faremo la
cheesecake qualcuno di voi potrà dire
che non abbiamo abbastanza inventiva la
realtà è che vogliamo darvi più opzioni
perché faremo una cheesecake salata che
cos'è un cheesecake salata lo dice il
nome è una cheesecake salata bando alle
ciance partiamo con gli ingredienti in
là c'è scritto dolce già vista questa
qua invece diventerà una specie di buche
tripudio di sapori dove la philadelphia
farà proprio da collante perché non
prima con la base per la base 150 g di
taralli e 50 dei crostini 100 g di
quando voi dovete fare la base mettete i
guanti modo da essere igienici e allo
stesso tempo sbriciolati crostini come
fosse il cuore del vostro ex così quindi
un pochino di dispiacere ma allo stesso
tempo che sotto sotto non vi dispiace
prendete a questo punto i taralli e
sbriciolati come il vostro ex
sbriciolato il vostro paese
intanto uso le mani ma poi minipimer o
comunque qualcosa che mi aiuti a ragazzi
quasi divertente mentre fate questa roba
qui divertiti di bassa stati cremosi
state allegri state scialli anche perché
solitamente nella versione dolce questa
roba si fa con i biscotti quanto è figo
che si fa coi taralli ma che genialata è
quando sentirete i crampi alle mani
capelli di essere quasi arrivati alla
fine
ma almeno qualcosa per andarci un po
meno cremosi è un po più di violenza
lei una tazza una tazza della willwoosh
family non si rompe che mi sembra fatta
posso dirti che hai ragione
questo è il risultato che dovreste avere
prete il burro e lo andate a aggiungere
io il burro questa volta l'ho sciolto a
bagnomaria perché non avevo con
microonde altrimenti potete anche
scegliere il microonde o anche tenerlo
fuori a devolvere al processo che vede
oltre a tutta una vita ma mai altro
punto a questa viene pazzesca ragazzi
scusate ma le porte ai case gioco
simpatico vorrei capire in che modo
compattare in maniera omogenea
cercheremo di farla carina garin a una
signora base a me sembra che stava solo
chi da anni non ho fatto il bordeaux
zigrinato erico sto combattendo una gran
mossa se ne assume andiamo a lavorare
alla crema lo mettiamo intanto in frigo
a farlo compattare per fare la crema
avremo bisogno di 600 grammi di
philadelphia 20 grammi di rucola un
mazzetto di menta e qualche foglia di
basilico
a questo punto apriamo il nostro pasetto
di philadelphia facciamo una delle cose
che mi mette più felicità al mondo
mamma mia e andiamo a prelevare e
philadelphia mi raccomando lavorate da
philadelphia che è importantissimo
perché in questo modo sprigiona la sua
remo sita secondo me ancora di più
almeno una mia convinzione a cosa
importantissima questi qui sono dei
piattini che sono stati messi in palio
da fino adesso che ti faccio vedere
vincenti in realtà è facilissimo basta
comprare confezione per due che vi ho
fatto vedere e dentro vedi tutte quante
le indicazioni per riuscire a scoprire
se effettivamente vi siete giudicati un
no basta andare sul sito viste cremoso e
mettere un codice a quel punto
incrociare le dita
ci siamo piccolo trucchetto personale io
a volte il tritato lo faccio così guarda
viene perfetto to separi meglio col
coltello assolutamente sì ma per favore
enrico tempo la testa ancora bene
basili conti è rammarico è una tecnica
pazzesca è così assurdo con le sto
facendo da assurda ma per favore enrico
fatemi sapere se un abominio fare un
tritato con le forbici e se nessuno l'ha
mai fatto nella vita
ora che sei felice rucola enrico mano la
mamma mia so già cosa stai facendo nel
sei ridicolo perfetto prendiamo il trito
e lo fiondiamo qua dentro
ma rimaniamo quando mangiavo molto poco
perché una ricetta facilissima ma può
fare anche chi sta attendendo in quel
momento la camera se un giorno volete
vedere enrico e fornelli visto che
parlata molto visto che abbiamo ancora
una sfida che gianmarco metteteci de
laica per ogni decina di migliaia di
like quindi 10.000 vale per 120 mila
vale per due il grado della ricetta si
alzerà a 50.000 incomincia a diventare
nuovo alto edificio di 60.000 incomincia
a diventare tosta tosta in modo che
enrico che sta sempre dietro quella
camera parla parla parla per una volta
ci fa vedere effettivamente che cosa sa
fare
esatto quindi spero che siano tanti
iniziamo a mettere like ma secondo me
questa roba viene una bomba viene
assurda tra dame occhiaia da in faccia
da pulire il bordeaux facciamole fatte
bene ste cose
saliamo leggermente
e mettiamo in frigo 30 minuti mette
aspettiamo andiamo a fare una delle cose
che adoro di più mi dà una soddisfazione
assurda quello che andremo a fare e
farci un bel posto c'è qualcosa per me
un ricordo tutti i giorni la vuoi non te
la faccio momento più difficile perché
benché io sia un artista quando si
tratta di adornare cose non è che sia
particolarmente bravo ma ho preso delle
referenze online e cercherò in qualche
modo di unirli all'interno di quella che
chiamerò della mezzaluna salata la
mezzaluna salata 3 ancora zoom la
mezzaluna salata per fare il cappello
avremmo bisogno di un'annunciata di
rucola fresca 67 fette di bresaola 10
olive nere 4 pomodori ciliegini
maggiorana origano e sale vi faccio
vedere come funziona brucola vi iniziamo
a metterla a mezzaluna salata se ci
riesco io ci riuscite pure voi il
brasile già così non mi fa impazzire
scoperto persone mammamia enrico
veramente cioè che non so perché ancora
ritengo quale il miracolo se ancora
sorriso davanti alle telecamere non so
come faccio devo veramente essere molto
falso è fatta bene interessante e bello
chi coglie la reference qua sotto mille
punta grifondoro interessante oh che
bello o motorini ma da tagliare
bravo quando andrai allevarla
per pregare che questa roba non funzioni
perché se no devi chiedere scusa a parte
che abbiamo già detto una cosa ilike
quindi mettete un bel like perché
vogliamo vedere cosa fa il nostro
professore ma qualora dovesse andare
bene cosa fa enrico e qualora dovesse
saltare male cosa famiglia elmo sempre
schifo perché figure mi pare dopo finale
fià che pensano che sembrano ma le
roselline di presa ora anche carire
grazie cittadini e tra chi si sente
veramente siete patetici per quanto mi
riguarda io credo ancora in questo
progetto in realtà ti prego cosa non ti
quadra cosa ti sta dando fastidio a
corta ricevono accozzaglia di roba già
dalla nuvola e ricorda sbagliato i cambi
con la camera viene farlo tu fammi
vedere cosa vuoi fare tuffi che non può
sbagliare
benvenuti allineamento ragazzi mezzo a
un piccolo angolo visto che il cavallo e
pareggio lettiere ci penserò io il
sottoscritto che non l'ho mai fatto in
vita mia ma sono più bravo di mio
fratello prima cosa avete un disastro
del genere barattiamo tutto cio un'idea
su come fare enrico insieme per
philadelphia enrico fratello questo
secondo me ci sta affidati perché è una
buona base per mete con il in meno però
che dici qualifica un quadrato neri con
affaccio la sera farà le proprie mani di
piatto già così e profumati club sakura
buttata così stonato cosa proponi dei
ciuffi e torte so bene perché tu vedi
quello che c'è sotto ma hai dei punti
dei punti di kami dell'ottimo una casa a
immagini
e di tutto quanto un arredamento
accatasti tutto in un anno in una merda
posso darti uno spunto creativo miti
addetti avete i colori minnesota il
minnesota la neve adesso devi arricchire
il paesaggio innevato chiarissimo odio
santo presepe fatto un ceto o no questo
non ci sono ci credo non è che vedo
tutta la differenza facciano cagare
entrati ragazzi lavigne appena da tale
consecuzione ma che se facendo abbiamo
con l'oliva funziona ma io farei più una
roba simile guarda che apertura tra
governi e certo ma abbiamo avuto di
bella bellissima si vede che l'ha fatta
mamma mia riconoscendo complimenti ecco
il mio compito qui ci ha visto non sono
soddisfatto perché a un certo punto
hanno fatto guglielmo però è meglio dei
miei rimasti fioretti rifà ai fiori come
dono di poterti riportare i fiori un
pochino di basilico rosmarino
questa è la famosa nere sul minnesota
maggiorana la facciamo scendere anche un
pochino in questo lato che vediamo da è
carino sicuramente meglio di quello
scempio di prima ma ha ammesso comunque
sia trova lungo la grande fissato questa
tegola grazie delle cose faremo sapere
agli aiuti in frigo per farti dare una
assolata e poi andiamo ad aprirle vedere
che cosa succede al momento della verità
finita che io sento un rock pazzesco è
arrivato il monitoraggio io sono pure
esiste o guardare che carica guardate
che figurone che fate con una roba che
si fa veramente veramente in poco tempo
giusto il tempo di aspettare che si
rapprende in frigo vado assaggiare mamma
mia
avete capito la base portante fino
adesso a cremosi simo perché è stato
lavorato la base super salata e quindi
dà ancora più sapidità al filadelfia
rinfrescato dalla menta dal basilico
[Musica]
consiglio belle la mezzaluna la saliva
per gli ospiti riempito ero totalmente
superata la mezzaluna più artistica ma
riempito tutto perché è un tripudio di
sapori in bocca promossa ragazzi se la
parete vaga dall'interno dello se
stories
ricordatevi chiede il pacchetto da due
di philadelphia ci sono le indicazioni
per vincere eventualmente dei piattini
come questo poi per esso ragazzi in
bocca al lupo iscrivetevi al canale
attivata campana notificate lasciateci
un bel commento qua sotto facendoci
sapere quale sarà la punizione di enrico
ogni like ricordategli ogni decina di
migliaia di laika sarà ancora più
difficile la ricetta dover fare chissà
magari proprio con philadelphia 1 fino a
renderla cucina troppo semplice dovrà
pensare a qualcosa tra il giovane per
lui